what if I just end up only showing slam
dunk videos okay my name is Ian Karmel
I'm a stand-up comedian and these are
some of my favorite YouTube videos this
is Sean camp of the Seattle SuperSonics
our IP not Sean camp he's alive but the
Sonics are dead dunking on this guy
Alton listed
[Applause]
it's my favorite thing it's amazing he
dunks on a guy super hard and then just
points at him that's why there was no
foul and the guy on the grounds like
you're right you did have to point at me
like he's not even mad about it he kind
of gets it like he's upset but he
totally understands the circle of life I
think this video actually inspired Elton
John to write the song circle of life
okay this is a Vince Carter who was on
the u.s. Olympic team dunking over this
guy Frederick vice who was on the French
Olympic basketball team he jumps over
he's a 7-foot tall man and Vince Carter
rest is the entire general unit right on
this gigantic man's forehead and then
Kevin Garnett gets so stoked about the
entire thing that he almost like punches
out Vince Carter oh no no no no no never
my since Carter almost punches out Kevin
Garnett which is almost even better if
he had jumped over a seven-foot tall man
and then punched Kevin Garnett to death
he would have ascended to heaven at that
point he would have become a god who had
a flaming sword and really dope shoes
[Applause]
this next one is my first time I was on
Conan just a classic stand-up comedy
said I have a girlfriend which is weird
because I look like I'm in the middle of
a really bad breakup really fun and it's
not me being cocky by the way that other
people liked it sukar Mel who's my
mother was like real stoked on it was
like a 15 favorite set from Conan that
year that's in the top 20 of 52 I found
out I was sad the other day I didn't
even know I was sad does this ever
happen to you I found out I was sad and
the way I found out I was sad was I was
at a jack-in-the-box
that could be the whole story all right
this one's the classic and you've
probably definitely seen it before but
it's the I like turtles video you know I
like turtles back here live at the
waterfront village with my friend the
zombie there's nothing really for me to
say about it except it happened in
Portland Oregon where I'm from Berlin
Jonathan you're looking good Jonathan
just got an awesome facepaint job what
do you think I like turtles
I think is the thing we're proud of
stuff it's like Matt Groening Eliot
Smith's happier times and then and then
this I like turtles video all right
you're great zombie and good times here
at the waterfront village okay this last
video is a music video that Adult Swim
did for this musician Dan deke and one
of my favorite musicians and it's for
the song called when I was done dying
[Music]
we've got a bunch of different animators
to do it and it's just this amazing song
and the videos amazing
if you watch it you'll feel like you're
on some sort of super weed that Denver
hasn't even invented yet but you know
they got their mind on it like some of
it like 2025 Denver that makes this
sound like it's some stupid hippie [ __ ]
it's not it's just an amazing song and
amazing video thanks for watching I hope
you like these videos
[Applause]
[Music]